forty-two million views for Tom versus
time on Facebook watch and the final
episode of the six-part
behind-the-scenes documentary series
airs Monday March 12th on Facebook watch
and it is all about the playoffs and all
about a Super Bowl loss and the man who
has been all about it with Tom Brady
Gotham Chopra good to see you sir
yeah thanks for having me so how did did
Tom need his arm twisted I know you guys
are in business together you and Strahan
and Tom Brady together for religion of
sports which you've been on this show to
promote before did Tom need his arm
twisted to do this you know I've known
Tom for five years and I've like been
relentless in terms of what he's been
doing for the last five years has been
historic so every season every preseason
every postseason I've been like Tom we
really got to do this Tom we got to keep
doing this and he's very polite you know
him many I would say no but this past
offseason a year ago he said hey gee you
know maybe we should do I'm turning 40
no one thinks I can come back or nobody
thinks I can do what I do at 40 I want
to show them I can and so that sort of
became the genesis but looking back I'm
also you know last season the prior
season with the way the season started
the suspension his mom being sick off
off the field the way the Super Bowl the
historic comeback I think all of those
things were like yeah maybe maybe I
should be capturing this and so in the
end it was kind of his decision well
it's also you know I know the way I'm I
am with my kids and that sometimes when
your kids start to get older you want to
record things for posterity you want to
make sure it's down for them to go see
later on right yeah
but then again when your Tom Brady and
you're opening up your world with your
children there to a camera crew even
though you might be friends with
somebody you call gee I'll call you
Gotham yeah and also you have a very
famous wife the other G the other G I
like that so I'm wondering did did he go
through
that process with you walking through
about what what you need shoot what you
couldn't shoot even though we trusted we
did overtime it changed I mean and that
you know I think what you said earlier
like his oldest son Jack is 10 years old
and Jack sort of at that transition
point where he's not just I have a 10
year old you see it it's not just a
little kid anymore it's like a young
adult almost like very aware and Jack
spent a lot of time with Tom over the
offseason traveling to Asia and I was
there for that and so it just sort of
like evolved like this relationship even
just between me and Jack and Tom and
everybody you know and everybody just
got more and more comfortable with it
and it's just when you're trying to do
something honest and if you have kids
yes the kids are the most important
thing in your life so like how do you
not have them a part of it and so look
ultimately it was like how do we just
make sure we're very respectful in the
Edit room and nothing ever went out that
Tom didn't see I mean this is his I'm
his partner
not like some guy from the outside world
coming to document his life
so obviously you can't control then how
people respond to it and there was
certainly some of that you know once it
was out there which I felt kind of bad
about honestly but Tom and gizelle have
lived in a fishbowl for a long time and
so nothing particularly surprised them I
think maybe in some ways I might have
taken and you know more personally than
they did you know their parents so they
feel protective but they also get it and
know where they are and who they are and
so you know they got over it pretty
quick so what what didn't make it in the
Tom Brady final cut in Tom Berg you know
like can you give me an example if
you've seen there's an episode we were
like in Montana playing like just
hanging out during the offseason with
Julian Edelman and Danny Amendola and
stuff there was a lot of swearing there
was a lot of gambling in that you know
it was definitely we called it Tom
called it gladiator camp okay you know
Tom Brady's version of gladiator camp is
like waking up at 5:00 in the morning
making protein shakes getting out to the
practice field there's a lot of swearing
and when he watched the first cut he's
like gee there's a lot of swearing do I
swear that much I'm I use for a lot
[Laughter]
but we cut down you know significant
amount of swearing well I mean that was
Brockman Chris Brockman over there was
my plus one for the NFL honors you know
where I'm going with this right I do
okay
someone Brady won the MVP award and
Edelman got up there and accepted I
don't know if you know where I'm going
with this - I knowing Jules okay yeah
okay he got up there and he said Tom
wanted me to say lfg I don't know what
that means
lfg and he leaves the stage you start
laughing Bravo I start laughing I know
what it means
oh yeah you know and the F stands for
something that's unmentionable right now
and it's let's go that made the final
cut of the show yeah cuz I tweeted that
out and somebody's like I didn't see
that so I don't know there's a lot of
bleeps and yes we had to bleep it out so
what did you learn about Tom that you
didn't know having known him for five
years he taught them show / by the way
the series creator and on occasion
director right yeah the camera oh yeah I
was like okay yeah so what did you learn
you know Tom's amazing at like compares
so much going on in his life like on the
field off the field in the locker room
like with dusty he said you know he's
twice the age of half of his teammates
at this point and so there's just his
ability to compartmentalize and deal
with all these things like literally
minute to minute he'll be in a huge game
and they'll lose and it's like it's
really depressing for him but then he's
got to like pick up the kids and take
them home and they're in the back of the
car and he's trying to get his phone to
sync with the you know car so he can
play moaña sing-alongs for his daughter
i mean he's a dad also so I've done the
same thing without you know though the
whole playing in the NFL and multiple
MVP trophy sand parties were vote one
yeah yeah that's what I was we both have
10 year olds we both you know have like
really cool hard-working wives but yeah
I don't know what about inside we we all
have trouble hooking up bluetooth to
cars but what what about Tom did you
learn inside you think look everybody
has this perception of him as
this robot almost like he's you know
almost inhuman he's you know he's a
thinker like he he notices every single
detail he was the first guy I was in
that you're you know in the green room
and I posted an Instagram he's the first
guy to like it like he's tuned in he's
tapped in it's not some guy I know
that's one break likes an Instagram it's
him that's him yeah yeah would you have
guessed that I would not have guessed
that he's just very like plugged into
everything that's going on you know and
he's watching the news he's listening
he's reading and at the same time he's
hyper-focused and obsessed with football
and watching tape endlessly and you know
just studying the game well I want to
take a break come back in 60 seconds and
I want to know what's in this final
series whatever you can tell me without
giving away all the goods this final
episode of this series about a playoff
run that involved a hand injury that
involved you know this ESPN article
about discord within the New England
house and then obviously a playoff loss
a Super Bowl loss with the ball we just
showed radio audience say a preview of
episode six just a the final play
it's amazing how close it came to being
in Gronkowski's hands in the end zone
I'm the Patriots fans I know it was
heartbreaking yes I know
so Gotham Chopra we're back with him
Justin Hartley if this is us in our
three and your phone calls as Richard
Sherman's been released the guy who once
told Tom Brady why you mad bro has been
released in Seattle and the Eagles have
made another trade unbelievable
that's all still to come back in 60
seconds with Gotham Chopra and Tom
versus time
religion of sports being on this network
first with the Gotham Chopra and
executive producers Michael Strahan and
Tom Brady Tom versus time episode six of
Tom versus time airs Monday on Facebook
watch and Gotham Chopra here before we
get to that episode and what what
goodies we can learn why don't you go
ahead and throw a theory out it's your
big patriot fan what you just said in
the commercial break when we met you and
Richard Sherman being fishermen one year
prove it deal it's like a Darrelle Revis
part too I think to New England yeah for
sure Richard Sherman now out there and
on the corner as long as he's healthy
well look I mentioned you
Brent Grimes right blew out his Achilles
at age 29 and ballin out since then
sizzles done it twice right so it's
possible tv12 method outs gotta go visit
across the street hate replace so is
there anything in the series about that
about that I mean like Alex yeah I mean
it's there right like Alex is a huge
part of Tom's life and ever-present
before every game after every game you
know so yeah I mean it's it's right in
front of your face and I think it's been
a challenging two years actually for Tom
just so much going on you know on and
off the field and this you know look Tom
he's had an 18-year marriage you know he
and that organization have had enormous
success do they see eye to eye on every
single thing no I've been married for
about that trouble with your wife yes so
you know but I think success I mean they
have the system and they all you know
especially it's interesting to watch
during the playoffs because like
everything sort of falls away like
there's a singular goal for a month and
all that other stuff to sort of gets put
to the side so how did the Patriots view
Tom versus time do you mean yeah the
Patriots were supportive like I mean you
know I was issued credentials and
and we never I was I'm a Patriots fan I
get the Patriot way I like benefit I
know that but part of the whole ESPN
article reading in top-to-bottom
soup-to-nuts is you know obviously I did
and everyone in this business is just
picking it apart that the fact that tom
has now and endeavor
other than just being the quarterback of
the Patriots is kind of new writer
relatively new relatively new right yeah
the first ten years it was all just you
know Tom taking hometown discounts and
winning Super Bowls yeah now he's got a
TV twelve method he's got his own shirt
guy who's telling him what to do with
his body he's got a religion of sports
he's got Tom versus time and that's not
the job I think he's being told to do do
you see where I'm going I totally get it
and though yet he wins MVP he goes to
the Super Bowl
again and so I had like any of those
things do not happened I think all of
these would be kind of you know things
we would have to talk about and there'd
be a lot of controversy but you know he
performs and I would argue that all that
stuff is additive to his he's a pretty I
think I don't I I didn't know him
fifteen years ago so I don't know what
was going on is I put all these other
things they add to who he is and you
know football is by all objective
measures Tom Brady should not be playing
anymore right like he's achieved at all
well certainly not playing at the level
that he's playing yeah but all loves
this game so much so and I think the
Patriots obviously see that his coach
sees that like you know they so there's
all ya there's things you've got to
manage and I guess there were more
things you had to manage this year but
at the end of the day I mean the team
just keeps on performing Tom keeps on
performing the coach keeps on performing
you know so but you know that the Alex
Guerrero Yoko Guerrero and this is the
Beatles here is that D would you say
that that's a fair assessment of this
situation Gotham best you can see I
think there's a lot of personalities
over there but I think Alex is a
incredible I mean I've seen it now yeah
you're also looking you're talking to a
guy whose father is Deepak Chopra
kind of like guys took you this long to
figure out that there's different ways
of doing this but you know i think i
think alex is a huge fart alex is not
going anywhere Alex
I mean I see before the aim after the
game middle of the week like it's real
and yeah I don't see how Tom Brady
continues to play and perform at this
level without Alex by his side Gotham
Chopra here on the Rich Eisen show
episode 6 of Tom vs. Tom over 42 million
views of this documentary already on
Facebook watch what are we what are you
what do we learn what are we seeing do
we see the hand injury stuff oh yeah
okay I mean it's great you see the hand
injury do you see it's it sallam took
iPhone picture of it like like within
minutes right I don't think anyone's
seen that so that's in there you like
that see how bad you see how he treats
it you know non-conventional ways you
know do we see the the concept behind
wearing gloves on both hands before that
press conference I mean he's the you
know um one thing I take full credit for
is like Tom's penchant for drama now
like you know he he knows how to
dramatize the moment so you know on both
hands saying we'll see you at the time
but you know he knew right you know you
knew I mean it was pretty it was bad
you'll see how bad it was okay and then
of course the runner to the playoffs and
how he deals with the aftermath which is
somewhat predictable I mean right and
but he's also now this parent so you
hear him talk about that I will say this
sort of a surprise ending if you listen
closely to the things he says okay look
he's a very different guy is at a very
different place in his life than he has
been
and so this offseason I think is very
different for him just in terms all the
things he's thinking about and so you
know watch carefully hmm a surprise
ending so it ends with him putting on a
Jets uniform is all right so that's
check that box that's not happening
when you're saying about things that
he's thinking about so it ends with him
pondering his own football mortality
would use like I don't think it's any
surprise to UM Brady's closer to the end
than he is to the beginning but yeah I
think he's thinking about a lot of
different things he's thinking he's a 40
year old man I mean you know that's kind
of what's at the heart he's looking down
the barrel of the gun and he's got a
long life out of him and he's only gonna
play football for so long I think you
know and he's a very thoughtful person
hmm and you did you did the documentary
Muse with Kobe yeah any similarities
between the two I mean just like that
devotion to the craft that perfectionism
that like on the field like I get the
nice Tom Brady for the most part I've
seen the you know the competitor in him
not just on the field but on the golf
course you know playing table tennis
with Danny Amendola and crushing
racquets and stuff like that so that I
mean that's a lot of Kobe but very
different personas also you know tom has
a gentle side I've never seen that with
the coach he's got the softer side so is
he deep down is he closer to complete
ball of mush or just some hard-ass red
ass competitor what is it I mean that's
the thing he's dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde I
mean I've never seen I mean I guess I've
seen Kobe so you know he's as
competitive as anyone I've ever seen
right on the littlest things and but I
mean he's got three kids including a
five-year-old daughter who just has him
wrapped her eye and know that it's
amazing my daughter's for my oldest son
is 9 yeah so I had the same interactions
with my 9 year old as we've seen Tom
have with you know with his son people
went nutty over and then in terms of the
daughter if somebody referred to my
daughter the way that somebody referred
to his daughter locally I'd have the
same damn reaction is him hanging up
local radio in episode 6 no it's not
there did you have any video of that no
I wasn't there when that happened that
was like the bye week we surprised
that he did um no I mean again I'm a
parent but you know what I was surprised
as 24 because what happened was he had
that reaction he was upset he hung up
the phone then he got on the plane he's
just possible way out of the way and
then hoped that the guy didn't get fired
well that's the thing he flew to
Minneapolis and there was all this drama
like everything happened and then he
landed and he was like guys relax I
don't want this guy you know and that is
that's very much Tom like he's he
doesn't hold on to these things you know
and he sees the bigger picture right and
that's pretty you know
impressive all right I'm gonna do I'm
Jim put you on the spot he says he wants
to play at least 45 do you think that
happens seeing what seeing I mean you
had a front row seat I see what he's had
to get to this level and play what he
must have to do I understand he's got
his guru and everything but what he must
have to do at age 40 to do what he did
this year I cannot imagine the
commitment and the hard work and the
blood sweat tears you have to do you saw
it up close do you think age 45 TB
twelves out there I physically
absolutely he could do it I mean I and
with very little drop-off in my opinion
mentally emotionally with all the things
that are going on with his family and
stuff like that
you know I'd I I don't know why he'd
want to to be honest so I I don't I
think 45 is I wouldn't bet on it okay
can't wait to see again episode six of
Tom versus time my phone rang off the
hook text everything tweets when I had a
cameo I guess was that episode 5s yeah I
mean when we were they showed it part of
game day morning mm-hmm when everybody
was talking about their MVPs and going
they were going oh yeah there's well if
somebody said Case Keenum and they all
they all went in the opposite direction
of the obvious they'd all just try to
come up with other names not name Tom
Brady and then I just conversation
freakin Brady Goebbels of that right now
there's a little bit of that in there
too but I also saw what I saw and what I
saw was as if I was the the most
valuable player of the National Football
League lfg rich I left
what does that actually stand for I'm
confused
thanks for coming on they've come back
anytime you got a Gotham Chopra here on
the rich eyes and showed the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience